la chronique de l'innovation avec
valérie auribeau bonsoir valérie dans sa
rue et on va enfin tout savoir du lit
filles on en parle depuis le début de
cette édition on va enfin savoir
concrètement comment ça fonctionne mais
oui est ce la faute du wifi wilfried on
peut se poser la question pourquoi pas
une start up de vélizy howlett com lance
le lit fit donc concept de transmission
de données par la lumière
cette nouvelle technologie est né grâce
à deux professeurs du laboratoire
d'ingénierie des systèmes de
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines cédric meyer
avec nous sur ce plateau bonsoir
respectivement et soit au-dessus
respectivement professeur de chimie et
de physique 1 pour savoir de quoi il
retourne exactement nous nous sommes
rendus dans les locaux de la start-up
oled comme créer en 2012 sujet en images
de guillaume cambis le lit fille ou la
transmission de données par la lumière
démonstration offensive le coup leur
musique différente si on les places 9
les haut parleurs sous une lumière ou
une autre on a les chansons différentes
le concept fonctionne selon un langage
binaire
si on part du principe de base que
l'informatique c'est 2 0 et des 1 on se
dit que si on étend une lumière c'est 1
0 si on la lui mme c1 si on fait ça très
rapidement donc les humains ne le
perçois pas mais l'informatique le
comprend donc on peut envoyer des
données comme ça outre la magie du
procédé
le l'ifi à d'autres avantages pad ondes
électromagnétiques contrairement au wifi
donc meilleur pour la santé
le lit fille se veut aussi écologique
puisque des lampes à led sont utilisés
mise au point en 2012 par deux
professeurs de l'université de saint
quentin en yvelines au travers de la
start-up oled comme les possibilités du
lift y sont infinies n'importe quel
domaine d'application petit avoir
recours
le particulier les musées mais aussi
l'industrie automobile pour des moyens
de sécurité par exemple on peut imaginer
un véhicule devant vous qui freina récit
votre temps de réaction n'est pas assez
rapide
les deux véhicules dont on communique
grâce à leurs feux à led avant et
arrière et permettra à votre véhicule de
freiner en cas de besoin la start up est
déjà en relation avec deux musées de
liège en belgique pour remplacer les
audio guides traditionnels par des
tablettes réceptive à la lumière pour
informer les visiteurs
ça
et je rappelle colette com a reçu le
prix national de l'innovation 2012 au
concours de création d'entreprises
innovantes du ministère de la recherche
et de l'enseignement son père supérieur
pardon et pourparlers l'ifi avec nous
sur ce plateau donc cédric meyer
merci d'être avec nous quel est
exactement le fonctionnement du lift y
on l'a vu brièvement dans le sujet donc
en fait le fonctionnement elle est
relativement simple
on allume en état en est un c'est zéro
on allume c'est un doux fait ça jusqu'à
un milliard de fois par seconde on peut
atteindre le gigabit par seconde
quand un système binaire mais c'est
vraiment excellent binaire c'est comme
du morceau petit con souvent l'asim ya
du manceau petit ça paraît très très
simple comme ça sert question des temps
et on rallume très très vite la lumière
en plateau on veut faire passer des
informations à faire passer les
informations axa va du simple message à
l'audio comme on a vu dans le reportage
de la vidéo et l'internet et les dos des
dons sont transmises par la lumière qui
est programmée en amont pour cela en
fait vous avez l'information numérique
qui va arriver jusqu'à la halle en poule
et l'ampoulé après l code et h
la lumière est ensuite de l'autre côté
vous avez un petit récepteur comme les
récepteurs qui sont présents sur des
smartphones et des codes l'information
et du coup vous pouvez traduire cette
information numérique qu'elle portait à
quelle distance on peut l'utiliser
écoutez en extérieur on peut aller
jusqu'à 15 mètres mais sinon en interne
dans les bâtiments il ya aucun problème
jusqu'à des murs ça pose problème
si à des murs la lumière traverse pas
les murs donc ça pose problème par
rapport au wifi alors c'est un acte fort
mais qui pour nous est une qualité
d'accord c'est à dire que pourquoi une
qualité tout simplement parce que le
wifi justement traversent les murs et
quand vous êtes dans des endroits pas
besoin de sécuriser et bien on pourra
pas utiliser le wi-fi le wifi sera
pressent encore justement on parlait de
de la nocivité du wifi du remplacement
éventuel du wifi car le l'ifi al'inverse
du wifi ne comporte pas de doute
électromagnétiques
mais il n'ya pas non plus de risque de
lésion oculaire
oui alors il n'y a pas de radiofréquence
vous
on est un allume juste des lumières
l'éclairage donc il ya passé
radiofréquences qui sont si nocive et
sur lesquels 20 l'om est fait attention
et émis des alertes
donc à grecque la lumière là gros
avantage l'éclairage à led c'est que
vous protégez vous naturellement de cet
éclairage vers votre ne va pas fixer un
éclairage à led et donc du coup vous
n'avez pas ce problème de justement
oculaire d'accord et le scintillement ne
perdure pas non plus puisque quand on
dépasse plus de 50 fois par seconde à
une l'état en fait vous voyez une
lumière constante
craignez-vous justement le wifi
craignez-vous de saison nous sommes
allez vous poser la question micro
trottoir et une fois devant le but qu'en
lui-même glace et je dirais presque
interdite pour les enfants ben ça fait
un peu peur oui pour nos enfants en
fonction d'avoir une box à la maison les
téléphones portables ou c'est vrai que
ça peut être nocif mais vu que c'est
invisible
je crois que c'est une crainte qu'on n'a
pas tout de suite on la voit pas donc
tout de suite ça ne nous effraie pas des
ondes on y est on en a toujours eu donc
depuis pas mal pas mal d'années je pense
que c'est quand un peu maîtrisée on se
répond serait pas assez fou je pense
pour sortir donc ce genre de technologie
sans avoir manque une certaine maîtrise
ça fait un peu peur mais c'est un peu
peur de l'inconnu quoi enfin pour
l'instant ça peut être démontré que qui
avait d une incidence mais c'est vrai
que bon quand même je pense faire
attention
petite parenthèse il faut faire
attention avec le wifi mais disons que
c'est vrai qu'on est inondé par ces
radiofréquences bientôt le 4g arrive
chez vous allez avoir des amplificateurs
justement douifi parce que ça passe pas
bien
donc à un moment donné il faut être un
peu vigilants et puis surtout faut
éviter par exemple d'avoir un téléphone
à côté du lit ou sous l'oreiller et
surtout chez les jeunes enfants qui ont
l'habitude d'avoir des téléphones très
tôt faute vigilants par rapport à ça il
faut avoir un minimum de précautions en
tout cas ça veut dire que pour le wifi
vous avez l'argument de respect de
l'environnement de la santé oms
également avec moi et c'est vraiment
l'élément fort pour le wifi c'est de
dire le lit fille n'est pas là pour
remplacer le wifi
wi fi à une certaine mobilité qui quand
même un peu restreinte par rapport aux
les filles par contre vous éviter ce
justement de polluants encore plus votre
atmosphère de radiofréquence les sur
certaines applications de l'ifi s'y
prête mieux que le wifi par exactement
donc partout typiquement balhous a
interdit le wifi dans les hôpitaux ou
dans les crèches on est vite mais dont
le lit fille pour être présent mais
après ça peut être des endroits où les
infrastructures métalliques par exemple
empêche finalement de claude wifi
fonctionne bien le l'ifi pour être
présents parce que l'éclairage or à
présent
donc on est vraiment complémentaires et
si on peut effectivement des endroits et
vite mais du logis parce qu'on peut
mettre du wifi ou train de faire alors
comment l'aîné le lit fille justement
que si vous n'êtes pas les seuls à
travailler dessus vers les etats unis
aussi depuis 2007 le lit fille aînée
réellement les premiers qui ont
travaillé dessus c'est au japon et
anniversaire cailloux qu'il faut savoir
plus difficile et l'aide
donc c'est la technologie des semi
conducteurs donc le pays du
semi-conducteur c'est en l'occurrence le
japon donc c'est eux qui ont commencé à
travailler là dessus
en 2007 le lis v a travaillé sur cette
thématique
tout simplement pour dans le domaine
véhicule on l'a vu à l'heure dans le
reportage où l'idée était d'utiliser les
cas rage à l'aide pour envoyer des
informations sur le véhicule qui précède
donc la leaf de la technologie wi-fi
hollis v a démarré par le monde vit par
le demande du véhicule de manu véhicule
comment protège-t-on une invention de ce
type ba les brevets donc là le sait
l'université de versailles qui détient
l'ensemble des brevets
que les hommes exploitent et donc il ya
que les brevets après il faut être les
premiers produits sur le marché
c'est la meilleure façon de réussir
c'est le cas de l agent pour le moment
tout du bois c'est le cas pour les deux
comme ce qu'en france sont actuellement
les seuls à développer produits à
commercialiser des solutions wifi est
justement vous développer cette solution
via oled comme la start up lancée en
2012 si le but de cette création
d'endroits l'arize toute la partie
recherche pour la vue est fait au niveau
de l'université cette start up et là
vraiment pour faire le transfert
technologique et donc connaître comme
hélas pour commercialiser développer
justement le lit fille et le permettre
que le wifi devienne quelque chose de
grand public et il n'entre après le
marché que ce soit professionnel ou
grand public
alors justement quel public parce que ça
peut toucher les particuliers mais aussi
les supermarchés les banques l'industrie
automobile le domaine est très large si
vous voulez parmi nos clients
effectivement on peut trouver des
applications et un supermarché
typiquement le nouveau chariot avec une
tablette où le client a besoin de
s'orienter grâce à l'éclairage vous
allez vous orienter vers le gérer le bon
rayon ça peut être effectivement la
butte à l'heure dans les musées s'est dé
nouveau type d'audioguides où le
visiteur
il a plus besoin d'agir sur la tablette
il arrive devant l'oeuvre
chaque oeuvre est éclairée du coup on
reçoit la formation voici par deux
exemples dans le grand public
bien évidemment ça sera déployée
l'internet donc chez vous votre réseau
d'éclairage servira aussi à finalement à
passer l'internet dans votre maison
et puis l'avantagé quand vous partez
vous éteignez la lumière tout va de
systèmes et à aujourd'hui vous éteignez
la lumière mais votre wifi continue de
tourner très peu de gens l'étaient et au
sein des banques c'est aussi
une façon de protéger ses données alors
au sein des banques mais c'est pas que
les banques ça peut être des industries
assez sécurisé aux défenses ou là très
peu utilisé finalement le wifi pour pas
être piratées donc il reste encore sur
des systèmes câblés la halle avantage
avec le l'ifi ceux qui pourront
justement permettre à leurs employés
d'être mobile et d'avoir justement entre
guillemets de l'internet facilement sans
pouvoir sans risquer de ce finalement de
l'information desservira la lettre le
wifi exactement parce que ça traverse
pas les murs donc la formation reste à
l'intérieur du bâtiment ça pour ça que
ça peut intéresser effectivement un
système bancaire est ce que ça ne
consomme beaucoup d'énergie ou pas non
pas plus d'énergie que d'habitude a
gagné un peu plus d'énergie que les
ampoules
non parce que on amplifie pas cette
lumière on l'a h
donc ça simplifie ça consomme pas plus
au contraire du wifi ou là vous mettez
en route qui a besoin d'alimenter aussi
donc si on espère marcher ça peut aussi
être une protection pour les personnes
qui ne supportent pas les ont vaincus
oui tout à fait c'est à dire que vous
exactement on n'augmente pas cette poule
i sur les trois magnétique
donc du coup les gens bon voilà on l'a
c'est vrai que maintenant pour que pour
que le wifi par exemple barda
supermarchés ont intérêt à mettre
beaucoup de bons actuellement même le 3g
passe parce que c'est une structure
métallique
donc c'est très difficile donc son
budget de mettre beaucoup
d'amplificateurs avec la lumière si vous
regardez en plus dans les supermarchés
dans les rayonnages d'éclairage à led
suit ses rayonnages donc c'est parfait
et donc du coup on peut diffuser
l'internet sans trop de problèmes vous
avez des marchés déjà justement alors
actuellement on a de la chance on a
beaucoup de demandes
donc du coup on a des on travaille
beaucoup avec des grands comptes
ferroviaires actuellement ça peut être
aussi avec des structures comme le type
edf typiquement ou dans leurs
discussions avec trois entreprises de
grandes entreprises françaises
donc voilà donc la actuellement
on n'est pas encore allé vers le gérer
le secteur commercial entre guillemets
alors demain cette solution pour écouter
de la musique nous avons visionné dans
le sujet chez les particuliers soit
possible oui là on nous sommes en train
de développer un produit grand public
pour la fin de ce premier semestre
ce sera un pack qui va s'appeler mahaleo
où on mettra en vente justement trois
ampoules qualifie avec une enceinte les
films et les gens pourront faire dans
leurs maisons des zones musical coloré
et justement écouter de la musique en
streaming par la lumière avec kelkoo là
c'est honnêtement si vous regardez c'est
le prix d'un paquet à peu près dans les
250 euros ttc non plutôt du haut de
gamme en ce qui concerne le wifi disons
clal aussi valence équivalent ça revient
à quelque chose comme 4 70 euros
effectivement l'an poule et quand vous
regardez une ampoule à led
elle sera multicolores on est avec 50 60
euros donc le surcoût y passiez excessif
au niveau de la qualité pour les
audiophiles
alors c'est la qualité gérait d'un savez
les docks pour ipod
iphone c'est à peu près cette qualité là
d'accord c'est pas on n'est pas dans
l'enceinte haut de gamme et ça dans la
sensibilité voilà voilà
parce qu'il remplacera le filaire et la
plaine voire ville n'était pas non plus
à la on essaie de faire quelque chose de
grand public avec une visite qui donne
un bon sens mais voilà on n'est pas un
peu faire plus dans le luxe mais après
c'est pas les matières et vu pourquoi
cette produit la fin de semestre 2013
vous voulez réserver déjà valu trois
salles et les lumières d'un la rédaction
voilà bien merci en tout cas d'être venu
nous nous expliquer ce qu'est le les
filles sont en augmentation de 17,8
on va passer à la jambe a maintenant
vous éclairer le plateau un complice
dans ces voix là ça vient vous clignoter
valérie l'agenda présent oui comment
fabriquer ça vous et dentifrice mais où
c'est l'atelier proposé par la maison de
l'environnement dès demain mercredi à 14
heures et samedi à 15h30 autre maison de
l'environnement échanges autour de
l'habitat bioclimatique ou comment vivre
avec son environnement cette rencontre
est proposée une fois encore par la
maison de l'environnement en association
avec l'agencé locale de l'énergie et du
climat pour permettre de répondre aux
questions sont vos projets d'habitat
neufs et anciens tout pour rénover sa
maison de façon écologique ce sera
vendredi 8 février à 20h30
merci valérie on vous retrouve donc
mardi prochain pour le prochain
rendez-vous innovation environnement
mardi prochain au même horaire nous
parlions de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin justement il ya
quelques instants et bien on y reste
mais cette fois ci dans la filière du
droit reconstitution de cette affaire
qui avait défrayé la chronique affaires
judiciaires la sphère dominici les
étudiants ont planché sur la
reconstitution du procès et leur verdict
et dans ce reportage
monsieur après les lions du zoo au
tribunal de grande instance de
versailles le procès de gaston dominici
commence
l'accusé dans le box les avocats ont
revêtu leurs toges les jurés ont été
désignés le président du jury peut
débuter son interrogatoire
tout semble réel sauf que gaston
dominici a déjà été jugé en 1957
vendredi dernier l'association
jurisprudence de l'université versailles
saint quentin proposer une
reconstitution de ce vieux procès où les
parts d'ombré au toujours persisté à
l'époque accusé de triple meurtre gaston
dominici avaient été condamnés à mort
mais aujourd'hui tout est encore
possible
il ya un véritable doute et du coup je
me suis laissé convaincre qu'il était
véritablement innocent et je vais du
coup essayer de convaincre qu'il a
lui-même innocents pour juger cette
affaire tout a été reconstitué les
preuves sont exposés des étudiants en
droit joue le rôle de l'accusé et des
témoins déguisements et accents compris
en
à côté des acteurs ont tenu un public
bouche bée des improvisations qui font
sourire alors la justice serait elle en
réalité du simple théâtre c'est beaucoup
de théâtre c'est beaucoup de comédies un
bon avocat
s'il plaide ce doit être un très bon
orateur s'il veut remporter ces dossiers
ne pourra pas si un bon orateur c'est
peut-être ce qui avait manqué à l'accusé
à l'époque car les jurés joué par des
proches des élèves ont déclaré cette
fois-ci gaston dominici non coupable
voilà pour ce point sur l'actualité en
ce 5 février merci de nous suivre sur
télé filet je vous retrouve demain en
direct et des et 18 heures avec de
nouveaux invités et notamment cette
question à partir de quel âge lancé nos
enfants dans l'apprentissage des langues
étrangères plus particulièrement de
l'anglais excellente soirée